assalamualaikum greetings of peace I'm
really enjoying talking with this week's
special guest dr. Jonathan Brown if you
guys were with us last week you got to
hear the interview that we're going to
continue on with this week we're talking
about the New Atheism know many people
get caught up in the trap a monkey see
monkey do and I think okay this guy's an
academic why would he be agnostic we
don't believe there's something anything
is a true atheist everyone deep down
inside believes we talked about the
research that was done proving this by
academics and he's an academic he
accepted the true purpose of life found
it in this beautiful way of life so why
don't we continue on with the rest of
the interview with dr. Jonathan Brown
and this week's show enjoy this is the
this is the venue this is the days of
the theme this is the video this is the
days you this is a amazing of french
philosopher had said that we have found
over time civilizations that were
without science or arts but none of them
without religion and we see that through
through we're not talking about people
now because obviously in Islam that
comes complete submission to the crater
it's pure monotheism only worship the
creator of the creation and you have
people if not worshipping the Creator
the end up worshipping maybe a abstract
idea maybe dictators a government a
system like you know communism whatever
the case but what do you think you know
when someone has to as they confirm that
this belief is acquired it's something
that you have to work hard to fight
against and nowadays you see many
Muslims monkey see monkey do they'll
have the professor they'll walk into a
class and sky is very intelligent I
think how can someone be so intelligent
and he's an agnostic or an atheist and
then Muslims get caught into this trap
and that now they start to you know go
towards arguing Darwinism and you know
what what do you have you been in these
experiences and talked to some house
maybe have enough yeah I mean I think
it's just very people need to understand
that reason is not a an independent tool
right so it has to be anchored either
you know incurred from below or angered
from above and you what that mean I mean
it's sort of like political parties I
mean you can find really intelligent
people become Democrats really tells you
will become Republicans I mean it isn't
obviously if intelligence was a faculty
that if it was you know the more intense
the Moores the stronger it is the more
likely it is to lead to certain
conclusion then you wouldn't have people
going to virgin to reckon directions
so you know is it just any it's
difficult because we're sort of taught
to say oh this person is really
intelligent therefore what they're
saying it must be correct actually
that's not true at all in any way I mean
people can be extremely intelligent and
then they decide that they want a
murdered and you know eliminate entire
race they can be in like James Bond
villains and always eat super geniuses
like I need to destroy the entire human
race so that I I mean so the point is
that intelligence doesn't lead you to
truth intelligence leads you to if you
know if you're rational it means that
you can follow it a chain of a sequence
of cause and effect very accurately but
if the either the original premise of
that sequence is wrong or any premise
that you insert in there at a certain
place is wrong then you're going to end
up with a wrong result so that I think
this is very important you know that you
did students understand this and that
intelligence is very different from
being correct on issues of metaphysics
or issues of truth so that's I certainly
try to get people to understand that one
of the direct results I think of people
turning away from from faith from God
from having that connection their heart
connecting to the crater is what we've
seen now too long go on Tokyo when you
had the stark stock market bust you had
people who had millions jumping off of
buildings but here I mean what do we see
like the antithesis here we see when
people actually have a connection with
the Creator at times like I was sharing
my story you know with the toe I mean
thank God it wasn't something worse but
we have an anchor we have a reference
points that we go to that it can always
be worse you know there's always light
at the end of the tunnel I mean what
what what do you tell when you have a
heart-to-heart with someone who's going
down that road what hope does a person
have at the end of the day you just
become dust you die you just go to sleep
it's finished you know and this is can
this be now this is the direct result
people jumping off buildings because all
hope is lost you know for example now
and this is kind of a silly example but
it always comes into my
number when I was and I was in my
visiting my friend in Las Vegas and went
to this block party I on his block and
there was this woman there and she was
saying you know I can't be religious cuz
you know my cat died and why would God
Oh kill my cat I mean I don't actually I
understand that because you know I'll I
used to used to have cats and I love
those cats yeah I mean they were my
friends and i love them dearly but i
think what this is a good example of
she's saying you know I can't but this
pain for her and this loss was so
significant that she couldn't cuz she
couldn't accept that somehow some some
God would allow this to happen yeah now
I think one of the that you often find
this in kind of weird popular versions
of Christianity that there's this notion
that the world is something is wrong
with the world and so you have to
believe in God in order to compensate
for that so for example you have to
believe in the redemptive power of Jesus
because Jesus has come to fix the world
so for Muslims you don't believe
anything's wrong with the world this is
that the cat didn't die because
something's wrong that's what happens I
mean animals die human beings die katze
run into the street and get hit by cars
of people run into the street get hit by
cars this is the SONA this is a son
unknowable law this is the way that
God's creation works there is disease
people get disease they die from the DS
people try to find cures for disease
sometimes they do sometimes they don't
this is what happens this is exactly
what God has planned for us and either
these things are these things are tests
for us their tests if you're my mother
died god rest her soul she died of brain
aneurysm in when she was in Ethiopia now
I could get upset about that and say oh
only she hadn't been the high-altitude
outside but she wouldn't have had this
plane aneurysm she wouldn't have died
you know so hang you know so angry about
this but you don't know that this is
what God God took her this was written
just had to happen okay and you know
instead of getting angry about that I'm
said about that this is a test for me I
said
I'm the LA thank God I had my mother in
my life thank God that she you know had
her her life thank God that you know she
guided me in certain ways thank I mean
II you don't think about what you've
lost you think about what you were
blessed with and you think that it is
always God gave us life God gave us
things he can also take these things
away from us as a test and that you fail
the test when you become angry and
ungrateful like the root of Khufu as I'm
sure you know Cara in pre-islamic Arabia
Arabic is actually in gratitude so
Crawford is in gratitude in gratitude
ultimately and so when you fail the test
is when you become when you hurl these
things back at guys I'm ungrateful why
did you do this why did you take this
from me God takes things promise because
this is the Sunnat of Allah and our job
is to not to to become ungrateful but to
still say hum do the law and when you do
that it's not just because you're not
just passing a test in God's eyes you're
actually happier as a person you're not
going on angry all the time always
always angry at the world we're going to
go ahead and take a break and we'll be
right back with more of dr. Jonathan
Brown here on the Dean show don't go
anywhere please subscribe to the dvo
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below please
also help support the D show by making a
donation in the link below subscribe
right now
you
tell me dr. Brown what was it for you
for me for example you know I came to a
point of my life and I really had
experienced many of the finer things in
life there was a empty void I started
searching and looking and really using
the gift of intelligence that God
Almighty gave us and at the same time
you know inside yearning to want to be
guided and I started to look too
different religions and in short what I
loved about Islam was all the the
authenticity of it its preservation when
I looked at just a basic book like brief
illustrated guide to understanding Islam
has a lot of the different quotes from
the Quran on science about the human
development up from the early stages of
the embryo the mountains I was
fascinated then some of the things that
from the way of the Prophet Muhammad
that he had talked about and I was just
amazed it wasn't anything that now it
was unbelievable the message was just to
believe in one God worship Him alone the
day of judgment that fascinated me what
was it about Islam that had you
fascinated and now you're living it here
with purpose today oh so when I first
learned about Islam I learned about it's
in class and university and I learned I
really learned about it through the
books of muhammad asad read his book the
message of the court of authority of the
the road to Mecca I read this
translation decrying the message of the
Quran and so I really learned about it
from a very i would say i'm sort of
modernist and rationalist perspective
and that's not in any way criticism what
i mean is that you know he has his own
perspective on islam and on the Quran
but I think that's for me and I mean to
this day I still believe this but you
know I think like you it was about you
know I'd taken a class on the
the old testament and i just said this
is i just i mean this is a great book
it's obviously very interesting but
there's just no way i'm gonna believe
this i mean as a religion i mean there's
just no this is so inauthentic it's just
so historically on non intact how could
i ever base my my belief i need
something that is intact i need it i
mean if you're going to start asking
questions about what a book means at
least you have to know the book is
intact so the first thing you know is
that the intact nature of the quran and
then the fact that you know human beings
are supposed to use their reason they're
not supposed to believe in things
because they're irrational or believe in
things because they are you know
outrageous you know like Pascal said and
then you know Bloods Pascal died 1662
and earlier Santa st. Augustine died 14
30 for 30 ad you know this idea that I
believe because it's absurd I believe
something because it's absurd sometimes
we can believe things that are absurd
and that absurdity doesn't mean that
they're untrue that's fine but you don't
I don't think you should believe things
because they're absurd right so you you
should be led to believe by reason and
then once you're your belief is
confirmed or your belief is set then you
need to write recognize it just because
certain let's say consequences are
certain things that might unfold from
that may seem absurd that doesn't
invalidate the original belief but I
don't think you believe in things
because they're absurd so I think that
really kind of the historical aunt Agnes
of the Quran and then the urge to use
reason was really drew me towards if he
struck me as being fundamentally human
requirements for belief it reminds me of
a lot of people you mentioned the
theology class or on the Bible many
people quote Nietzsche is it he also
took a theology class came out of it and
was like this stuff doesn't make sense
and went towards acquiring
agnosticism or atheist ism there's a
quote that people they love to quote him
i think is god is dead and there's two
interpretations I heard to this it's
possibly he meant it for him or the
people around him is his people at that
time had gone away yeah well I think
what he meant I mean obviously me cheese
a very profound and sometimes
unsystematic writer but I think what he
meant is that I think the full quote is
you know god is dead I think we we have
we ourselves have killed him or
something I think it's the original
quote as a guy is talking about reading
a newspaper or and the headline is god
is dead this is we ourselves are killed
my camera the exact context of the quote
but I think what he meant is that
European society in the late 1800s had
already moved beyond a belief a kind of
a Christian belief in God it was that
that that that belief was in effect
obsolete for that society that that
society had killed God and it you know
for Nietzsche that wasn't necessarily I
mean that's not in and of itself bad it
just means that people need to come to
terms with the moral universe that they
are created for themselves and if you
sort of if you live in a post if you
don't really believe in God anyone you
continue to live in this world where you
have God but you're not really living
according to that then you there's this
sort of internal contradiction and
hypocrisy that is going to there's this
dissonance in your world view that is
going to hobble you that is going to
prevent you from moving forward so he
wanted to kind of super supersede that
that post that sort of early postmodern
or you know late modern 19th century
world view I think that so when he says
god is dead I think what he's saying is
that modern and then post modern
European of Western civilization yes it
killed its belief and
and that's true I mean but it you know
you don't that doesn't mean that it just
means that's the belief of a certain
society it doesn't make it true and true
yeah I have no doubt if he would have
walked in and took a theology class of
the basics of this universal message of
peace acquired by submission to the
Creator not the creation he will he
would have learned of the pure
monotheism of Islam original goodness
you know I often make this example if
you got a computer and it was full of
viruses you understand to be happy with
that so the concept of us being born
with a stigma attached to us this
doesn't make sense to the human being
nor worshiping a human being other than
God but when you talk about worshiping
only the one who created Jesus Moses
Abraham not the Sun not the moon nothing
in creation but the one who created
creation doing the best that you can be
to be the utmost and righteous person
and then the concept of accountability
day of judgment something about this
pure message of Islam it just resonates
with the heart connects with the heart
and I believe that if people like him at
his time and people today if they would
give Islam a shot and sit back humbly
earnestly looking at it sincerely that
they would also recognize it as a truth
what are your thoughts I think that
Nietzsche would not be become Muslim if
you learned about basic Islam come on no
no but I the reason I think that is if
he will sincere now people sincerity and
he I think I think that if you took
michi as a child yeah put him on the
island so you'd be mouth you know much
more about it everything with people I
mean by the time people are let's say
their millionaire their teeth their
teenagers or their early 20s I mean
they've already the lot of their
background beliefs are very firmly sets
and thumbs up days they can change those
beliefs but the power of custom and the
power of convention what the people the
people here about the message of Islam
from the Prophet what did they say you
know we did not find our forefathers
doing this
you know why do Americans wear shoes in
the house it's ridiculous to wear shoes
in the house I mean think about you walk
outside you step in dog poo you walk
into your house but you know sometimes
you watch people when they Americans
really talk about you know Orientals
taking their shoes of those oriental
custom it's actually really intelligent
thing to do but people don't want to
give up what they're used to even the
power of custom the power of culture is
so strong it's so strong and even if
it's irrational even if it's baseless so
you know when you look at nici's thought
I mean I think he was so fundamentally
believed in the that it was human beings
who create meaning and that human beings
have to kind of rebel against the gods
rebelled for the get against the divine
and that's how they create meaning I
think that he died was so stuck in his
mind that I don't think that he could
ever have believed believed in a
religion that was about submission
because for him submission was
fundamentally if you're being tricked
into submitting if you were submitting
you're being tricked into submitting and
that so I think that I'm gonna want to
sit and talk about needs you too much as
1 i'm not an easy specialist to does not
the point of this discussion but I mean
that I think that it would make a maybe
better point which is that if someone
believes its submission is in and of
itself unacceptable then you can never
get them to submit I mean no matter what
you tell them they're submitting to but
what about if somebody because we know
there's hindrances obstacles to
connecting with god one is your desires
write another one can be imitation of
society write another one arrogance is a
key but if someone might have had a
calamity in their life now they've been
humbled for whatever reason and they
earnestly at that point they realize you
know what I'm not truly self-sufficient
and they truly like deep down inside
they called upon God alone and they were
like really trying to let's remove some
of the obstacles any person be it an
agnostic and atheist whoever's out there
whatever professor no matter what you
know
class they come from if that human being
now sincerely wanted to know the truth
and within themselves at that moment
whatever you know we all have those
moments but like you mentioned kids you
know work everything you know Clowes
division clouds the mind you're just you
know trying to rise that ladder to the
top of whatever on Shalit's you know
wherever you're at but if that person is
being sincere with themselves with God
would they find what they're looking for
in Islam and what God guide them if they
were sincerely asking because I asked
many people I say look have you ever
thought about the purpose of life have
you ever even asked the crater for
guidance and if they did that wouldn't
god I'm at his mercy guide them um you
get the question yeah I do I mean I
think God guides whoever God wants the
guy yes that's I mean so I can't say
that's God would always do this or do
that but I would say that I think the
most dominant one of the most dominant
features of the human being is it's the
human power to forgets I mean if you
think about I mean this is also the
doctor who episode the Ptolemaic talks
about that but I mean that the point is
that you know you how is it that you
take a human being you he human being is
on an airplane the airplane starts
jumbling about the person's calls out to
God sincerely booklets in lihue 15 and
says you know please God say if I if I'm
safe from this I'll believe and I'll
search for the truth I'll do whatever
you ask of me and he's saved then the
person immediately just thinks either
doesn't think about ever again it says
oh well the plane was going to land
anywhere I was just you so the point is
that people forget all the time they
willingly forgot they willingly dismiss
their experience and that's one of the
features that the koran talks about
human beings are forgetful they're
always forgetting and that forgetfulness
is you know allows people to continue
even after they've had maybe proof of
the truth or experience with the truth
and what I think sets apart people who
accept guidance is the ones who
who don't forget at least long enough to
to accept the guidance that's given to
them so again that some people think
it's always about reason and whether
some sincere something it but a lot of
times it's just people forget yeah he
will always forget what reminds me when
you look back and you look at oman even
a tablet or gunawan if you look at halle
didn't will lead if you look at through
mama even a thought he was on his way to
know that was all mod he was he was
going to kill the Prophet peace be upon
him so imagine how much hate you have
there for Mama even without he was an
enemy of the state he also he was the
leader of one of the tribes at that time
and he also had tried to kill the
Prophet peace be upon him and he had
said I had never hated anyone as much as
as I hated you i had never hated a
religion as much as you he was a hater
he turned into a lover so my point is
these people they try to kill the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him but
one thing once can you imagine he's tied
up in the mosque her mama he's hearing
the Dawa he's getting to hear the pure
message of Islam what's going through
when people actually when they cleared
these prejudices these biases and they
get to sit sincerely and hear the pure
message because of what we have this
fitted ah right so my point is what are
your thoughts on that when you know if
because somebody now is a professor God
guides them to watch the Dean show I'm
trying to to spread that message of hope
for everybody you know and give a shot a
try because you're an academic you gave
it a shot a trot you're here with us
today I didn't show I mean I think that
I would hope that people um you know ask
themselves this is some of the question
that I asked myself when I learned about
Islam is it do you are you looking for
truth if you find the truth will you
follow it if you're not looking for
truth then who cares whatever go your
way if you don't care if you find the
truth you rather continue with what
you're doing and don't want to bother
yourself okay then fine but if you are
looking for the truth and if you will
find it when you see it
then be serious about that you know
follow that logically don't think about
how much it's going to hurt or how much
means you change your lifestyle or
something like that you know follow the
truth if you want if you seek the truth
and if you'll follow it where you find
it then then do so and that's I think
what you when you see that the Arabs the
time of the Prophet let'slet's alam
their their culture was this very I mean
I had a lot of problems but it was
really a very direct culture people
didn't cloud their decisions a lot so
you know if they believe something they
did that but they didn't believe
something they didn't do it right i mean
you know that's why people would come to
that you you see they come to the
Prophet they would experience something
say I believe you know and then they
would follow the Prophet so they you
know of course you had you hypocrites
and they're people who later their
belief faltered but I mean when you a
lot of the Arabs in the town of the
profit they make these decisions that
are really you know if I if someone
convinces me something is true I'm gonna
follow them and then they do that yeah
they don't say someone couldn't see the
truth I'm gonna follow them than they
like yeah but you know I really have you
know I need to go back home and I've
cooked for dinner and stuff like that so
they're they're very direct in their
decisions which is something that is
admirable a couple more questions we're
almost out of time someone is watching
the Dean show you know they're
connecting with you you're a professor
you know they're searching for meaning
in life purpose in life you know they
like this message of they've
investigated a little bit more the the
worshiping the creator of the creation
the full system of Islam helping you
develop to be a the best human being
possible they hear a lot of derogatory
things against Islam they keep hearing
this I mean radical Islam being thrown
out there is no such thing as radical
Islam Isis you hear Donald Trump you
know people having a certain agenda
using Islam now to create fear and
division and and the person says look
dr. Jonathan Brown why is all the chaos
in the world violence a trip
to Islam and they're scared of it well I
tell them it's very simple I mean look
don't just because people say stuff a
lot doesn't make it true I mean it's I
know that's ah sounds obvious to say but
if you think about it you know people
say stuff so I mean I remember one time
I was on the airplane a couple years ago
this guy gets on the airplane to the big
beard I got scared I mean you're like
you know I mean I was like oh Muslim
when I got how can I the point is that
you know even if you know someone people
when it surrounds you constantly it
becomes like truth to you and you people
have to know that they have to resist it
and just and you have to just sit down
sit back and ask yourself what's
actually happening okay if you actually
look at the world I mean you know this
physicians for Social Responsibility did
study about two years ago I by a year
and a half ago do you know any people
have died since because of the war on
terror I think you I think it was 15
million people I mean since not since
nine eleven if I hope I'm quoting this
correctly physicians for Social
Responsibility you can find the report
online if I'm wrong somebody correct me
I'm just self-taught my head about 15
million people died since I mean they
did you know every day like on a dowry
killings in India every year in Delhi or
in India there's like some 5 verse five
to seven thousand women are killed in
dowry killings in it but in Hindu
Indians no one even knows about that in
the United States all they hear about
the honor killings they're more honored
there's more honor killings in one you
know in one day in delhi among Hindus
then or all the Muslims that you've a
challenge you to find out data on Connor
killing in Muslim countries in one day
in delhi that's probably more dowry
killings then in the muslim population
in the world in that time frame so I
what my point is that people they don't
they hear so much about Muslims and
violence Isis and all this stuff you
look at the number people Isis ago I
don't like Isis okay I don't support
Isis you know there's lots of things
they do that are absolutely unacceptable
but if you look at the number of people
let's say that the Egyptian government
now
as in prison number of people that the
Egyptian government killed since the
coup of 2013 I mean you're talking about
thousands and thousands of civilians you
know maybe dozens of thousands of people
in prison wrongly being tortured and
raped in prison when is you know what
what's the difference between that and
Isis really i mean you know you're
talking about governments or
organizations that kill thousands of
innocent people in prison or torture
thousands of innocent people but no one
thinks about you know here's how a bad
Isis they don't think about other things
that so they're convinced that somehow
Islam leads to these evils but there's
exactly the same number of Evil's or
amount of evil being done by something
that's obviously on that's not justified
by Islam at all we're not even
attempting to justify itself so I think
this is you know Isis exists because the
United States invaded Iraq and destroyed
all the institutions that country and
left it a complete mess that's that's a
fact okay Isis doesn't exist because of
Islam because Islam was in Iraq before
2003 and there was no Sunni extremists
there was no Sonny terrorism there was
no Isis before 2003 this result this
emerged in Iraq app because of the
United States invasion that's what
caused Isis Islam didn't cause Isis but
if you look at the US media it's
obsessed with getting people to talk
about Islam the cause of Isis Isis
because of Islam why does it do that
because the function of media and
government is to prevent people from
actually in this case prevent them from
actually reflecting on the actual causes
of this phenomenon which is United
States unjust war mongering because if
people SAT there and said hey wait a
second we got talked into invading this
country it was a total disaster now we
have this Isis business then they might
say hmm maybe we shouldn't go and invade
countries the next time we're asked by
our government to support a war that's
not what the kind of power elites are
the military media industrial complex
once they want people thinking like that
so they have to sit and place the focus
on some other cause it was cuz of Islam
they don't want Americans actually
thinking about really cause these things
so when I when I what I tell you you
know Muslims or even non-muslims about
this is don't be bamboozled by what you
see on TV is very simple I mean I know
it's obvious but just because people
stays
for lot on TV doesn't make it true and
you have to practice I mean you really
have to practice and make no I'm I I
know my was getting super angry at me
for saying this but like for example if
you believe that people are guilty until
proven innocent you really have to stick
to that I mean and you had to practice
so for example Bill Cosby I don't know
what Bill Cosby did he may have raped
all these women and if he did that's
terrible but the bottom line is he's not
been proven guilty yet they got has to
have a trial so is tempting it is just
sit there and say oh he's guilty of all
these things know if you believe that
people are guilty until proven innocent
you have to hold that belief and say
even if you despise somebody even if you
despise with your accuser even if you
think they're almost certainly guilty
you have to say this person is not
guilty until they've been proven so in
court of law because this is what this
is how the media function functions to
make us forget the processes that we
have in place to prevent us from acting
on emotion like due process like the
presumption of innocence these things
are so important to keep in mind last
question tell me for the person now a
lot of times I mean it's very clear
anyone who reads a verse before and
after you know for instance and in the
crown of a reading Word of God God
Almighty is saying chapter five verse 32
ever kills you know one innocent being
as if you kill the world saving one
innocent life as you saved the world and
so many teachings of mercy and
compassion the one who as the Prophet
peace be upon him said the one who's not
merciful to God's creation God won't be
merciful to them and this is for all of
mankind but now you have many haters out
there who when you go ahead and you try
to illustrate and show you know the
mercy of Islam what do you say you've
actually written a book misquoting
Mohammed they will attack and they'll
say you know what kind of profit was
they call him a pedophile they'll quote
different verses from from the Koran and
violence and what not too many points to
cover but there's so many misconceptions
we know there's no honor killing Islam
there's no forced marriages all of these
things are just how
baloney phony whatever mumbo jumbo but
what advice do you give from someone
who's been affected they've been
affected by the false media hype and
also people you know if hate throwing
one verse out there and now they're like
bewildered all you guys are just
sugarcoating it you cover a lot of these
things in your book yeah i would say
read my book on this coating mohammed
that's why i wrote the book one of the
reasons I wrote the book yeah but but
what are you in a nutshell for somebody
now maybe they don't have time they
don't they don't have time to go and
purchase the book what advice do you
give this part the message of Prayer
monotheism you know they like the
message that Islamic and say that you
have the keep in mind that the world is
a human the world is a bigger place than
urban America okay the world is a bigger
place than daily show audience I mean
what I mean is there there are things in
the world that you think or you are
going to think are weird and that you're
not going to like and that doesn't mean
that those things aren't inherently
wrong it just means that they're you're
not used to them like people in some
parts that will eat dog meat Americans
think eating dog meat is absolutely
disgusting I mean you know Eric ins if
you sir the dog they're going to get
physically sick like this is unnatural
to eat this but then there's other
people in the world are you dog me they
love it so you're you feeling something
is revolting doesn't mean anything it
just means you think something is really
you've been taught to think this is
revolting it has no proof of anything
that's what I would say to people just
don't don't just simply dismiss somebody
because it seems weird to you all the
time you have to look into it is there
is there really a reason that this is
wrong that I should reject this or is it
just my preconceptions the way I'm used
to looking at the world misquoting
Muhammad yes we're going to get the book
the book store no I mean I don't know
places you get books you guys know where
to get focused amazon.com cold storages
so someone wants to get a little more
detailed and really you know academic
really or just someone who wants to want
answers to some of these more yeah I
mean wants to investigate that's not
miss kori mohamed yes god bless you
peace be with you we started with pilau
otic thank you
alaikum Salaam and don't forget
subscribe right now